this video is sponsored by manscaped
which means we will hear more from them
in the middle of the video hello
everyone i'm alana and welcome to my
channel where today i'm doing something
that people request a lot but that like
kind of sucks to do so i've kind of
avoided it and i've just done it
carefully right now this is a video in
which i google myself um and the reason
that i don't want to do that is because
like
there's so much internet stuff that i
just don't need to see i just don't feel
the need to see any of it and if i look
for it it'd just be a bad time sometimes
i have trouble even browsing reddit
because i'm just like looking at a video
game subreddit and then
i see my name come up and it's like
something that's completely wrong that's
the thing that i've said is very strange
about being any level of public figure
even at like tiny little one-way like i
am is the amount of people who
lie about you is too large
for you to correct them it would be all
of your time and it definitely sucks to
watch other people
just blindly agree with it and you just
can't even comment you have to be like i
just have to let this happen because it
is it would be a full-time job to care
so i just don't even pay attention to
any of it however
a lot of these articles on
all of these websites this one is called
biography mask are often
very funny um largely because they're
completely incorrect though her
nationality is not review and is
australian and ethnicity is unknown
my favorite thing about this one is
birthday august 24 1993 accurate
birthday august 22 1993
it's on the same page
alana pierce became the miscellaneous
crew and producer for her works on
sunrise that's really good what that is
is just sunrise is an australian tv show
that i guested on and was interviewed on
a couple of times regarding gaming
and i became the miscellaneous crew and
producer
would say i was like a guest host would
be what i did for sunrise probably after
working along with bbc gamebug in real
feed she made her job at ign
entertainment as an editor in 2015
through under toys and culture section
that's uh somebody translating my
linkedin for sure i love the net worth
ones these are so funny
according to sources so you know they're
good her estimated net worth be around
one million
this is also my favorite people
frequently will come to me and be like
hey i read that you make a million
dollars a year on google and they'll
like screenshot it to me as proof
that i make a million dollars a year
which i absolutely do not and they think
that that
sources
is good
what no i do not make a million dollars
a year being popular on social media is
the primary source of income that has
literally never been true my primary
source of income was ign and then roost
d that is now santa monica studio that
has absolutely
never been correct you know what
we can't beat this this is my favorite
part
as per 2019 alana pierce is in relation
to a member of rooster teeth
production's blaine gibson they are
unmarried yet the couple met first for
while they were in san francisco and
started dating
not not true but none of it is the
beautiful pictures of the couple are
often uploaded
it seems there is eternal love between
these lovebirds there is no sign of
separation and then they have a picture
of me and james williams a lot of people
their boyfriend blaine gibson spending
time on beach sauce instagram
me
james williams no blaine and i broke up
in
2018. beautiful pictures of the couple
are often uploaded this is my favorite
this is the best sense that i've ever
read
alana pierce went through mental
distress when she used to receive rape
threats and sexual threats from
teenagers
oh my god that's incredible i feel like
i should address
that
when i went viral for contacting
people's mothers for sending me rape
threats this part is true i just assumed
they were from grown men and then i
looked and i realized they were from
teenagers
no part of me was mentally distressed by
that experience
i mostly
thought that
getting their mums involved was
funny i did also think that that it was
a good way to get
a real world consequence for things that
like kids are doing online and to teach
them not to use that language
because of course it can be damaging to
people but i feel like from the jump
i was always like i realized they were
kids and i was like oh i'll just contact
their parents then no mental distress
when i receive threats from teenagers
thankfully that is incredible though
okay this one is called riveting facts
you need to know about alana pierce the
video journalist video journalist
video journalist okay it's fine um born
in australia august 24 they got that
right
daughter of susan makes my mom sound so
[ __ ] cool she is the daughter
of susan she bagged i bagged a bachelor
of
arts degree in mass communication what
what
it is time to talk about manscaped and
manscaped.com which is the global brand
for men's grooming and hygiene products
i very much enjoy this partnership with
manscape because you get to say things
like they make products to help with
your big three ota zones your butt your
balls and your body but also because i
think men's hygiene is important i know
you can get the ultimate manscaped
experience when you purchase their new
performance package 4.0 bundle with the
performance package you never have to
worry about a complicated multi-step
grooming regimen it's an all-in-one kit
that includes all the tools to perfect
your grooming experience of course most
people i assume do their grooming in the
shower which is where the lawnmower 4.0
comes in handy this thing is shower
proof and cordless
so sleek it has replaceable ceramic
blades up the top here which have skin
safe technology and a built-in led light
this right here is anti-chiefing
bowl deodorant okay
okay and then we have the crop reviver
this is a refreshing ball toner with
active ph control oh that's also lovely
they also sent me a uh weed whacker
which is specifically for things like
your ear or your nose hairs so when you
opt in for the full performance package
4.0 kit you get the biggest bang for
your buck you can enroll in their peak
hygiene plan and get ongoing
replenishments of your favorite products
delivered straight to your door hassle
free so go to manscape.com today and get
20 off plus free international shipping
plus two free gifts when you use promo
code alana 20 at checkout this is
ridiculous
you think
that i've ever made 470
thousand dollars annually from my
youtube channel
literally
ever
what is wrong with you
no
no
oh my god what
what
she has multiple sources of income is
correct is reportedly making as much as
470 000 annually from her youtube
channel is insane
in view of that it's easy to believe
she's worth one million dollars well
thank you
but no
all right what are ten
things you didn't know about alana
pierce give me ten exciting things she
loves to hang out by the water
is true also
when did i say that
just because alana is a gamer doesn't
mean she can't go for a swim as we know
game is all burned down the minute that
they touch water
uh doesn't mean that she likes to spend
all of her time in the house sitting in
front of a screen she also enjoys being
outdoors and getting some fresh water
whenever she can she loves to hang out
by the beach and good body with friends
batteries like you're describing me like
a dog that somebody is about to adopt
she's well tempered and is happy to be
around other pets loves to hang out by
the beach and is happy on a boat with
friends adopt your alana today this
one's got to be good just based on the
quality of this image it's it's recent
though milan appears wiki age boyfriend
height net worth however a gaming
journalist can only be someone like
alana pierce who is professional to her
duty
worth noting that in 2010 i was not
sorry 2020 i was not a video game
journalist but it's okay
did she leave her gaming journalist job
for youtube alana pierce reached 27
years of age on her 20-20 birthday
that's true
august makes her a virgo also true born
to her parents never ruled much about
her family including her hometown and
siblings too
no i definitely
have i was born in cairns and i have a
sister she endows body measurements of
35 25 35
what
that's got to be that they looked at
like average
women's
measurements there's
no way that's right
just for five foot ten
what hold on is quite an oldie on
twitter
not just youtube alana pierce is famous
all over the internet including
instagram twitter and facebook alana is
quite an oldie on twitter
unlike most celebrities get wrecked
celebrities i'm an aldi on twitter many
prefer ig and even facebook over twitter
but alan is very famous on twitter too
with over 437 000 followers well at
least this one
is lesser i do not have anywhere near
850 000 to my name to be clear nowhere
close to that however at least you're
not saying she probably makes that much
from youtube every year this is from tv
guide time alana pierce is one of the
renowned youtube gamer voice entertainer
and author whose ongoing tweet on her
twitter has been moving at this point
in that tweet what tweet she has
referenced that she will miss working
for both groups while expressing
gratitude towards funhouse inside gaming
people group incredible what a sentence
oh look at you go net worth 1 million
again
keep going for it web star is my
profession they they always get my
height and they always just think that
mum is just it that is it where is a lot
of pierce going all things considered
alana pierce's ongoing post has placed
everybody in stun for leaving the
chicken teeth people group
this is my favorite
this is clearly just like badly
translated
chicken teeth people group
that's amazing all things considered she
has a tallness of 5 feet 10 crawls with
appealing body highlights at least i
have appealing body highlights
that's good to know a lot of psk
charlotte is born on august 24 1993 he's
a famous australian american what a wild
weight guess shoe size five how do you
think i'm gonna be five foot ten with a
size five shoe
what
absolutely not no
that's a tiny foot my god religion
christian also absolutely not
lucky number nine
huh where did you even get that from i
don't even if i've ever said that i have
one i don't think i would have said nine
oh they have a picture of chelsea
sweet baby school local private school i
actually went to a public school i did
not go to a private school we didn't
have the money
my parents did not have the money to put
me through private school so
i went to kedron state high in brisbane
which is a public school born into a
christian family no i wasn't
i don't think any of my family members
are christian my dad's side of my family
is mormon
my mom's side of my family
i would say is entirely atheist i was
not born into a christian family did you
just guess that where did that come from
her father is a businessman and her
mother is a homemaker how dare you do
that to my mum that
not that there's anything wrong with
being a home maker to be clear
no my dad uh is not a businessman
my dad is a tradesman so um he's a
boilermaker a person who and i guess
kind of a carpenter person who would
build stuff or or
my dad did a lot of welding um so like
worked in construction
um before going into uh he worked it he
did like promotions at a bar
he is now a building manager
my mom
pretty much my whole life
has worked in administration she's an
accountant right now but has virtually
always been like
in an administrative office i also find
it very funny that my they think my
sister is named twinkle snap because
that was one of her handles once this is
a picture of us together what a key
picture to specify her body highlights
alana has normally light hair and dim
earthy colored eyes praise her charming
face
i think we need to leave this one she is
honored with an immaculate body
estimation of 36 28 35 where is this
coming from
where is this coming from this what who
are
where is all of this money
we can assume that her net worth is not
less than millions of dollars no you can
assume that my net worth is less than
millions of dollars that is horseshit
being a celebrity she definitely earns a
decent amount of money through some
deals commercial ads and endorsements as
of now she lives a lavish and luxurious
with our family members in a lavish
mansion
what
i live in a studio apartment right now
um it's about 400 square feet
um
that means there's no bedroom there's no
office my lavish mansion
has a bed which is a mattress on the
floor
and then next to it
directly next to the tv
um my pc is in my kitchen and then the
only other thing is like there's a tiny
bit of a hallway and a bathroom has a
little shower and a toilet
that's my whole living space
um
lavish and lux luxurious with her family
members in a lavish mansion
she's not disclosed the information
regarding a house's car collection and
other assets
don't have them
literally no cars
none
absolutely none of this
um you can update this as soon as you
would like to say
this is all garbage
all of it is not true
my god okay this is the last one not
just a streamer or gamer but there is
also a bunch of games news about it
spread in the media what
[Laughter]
alrighty everyone this was super weird
but is also very funny thank you all for
joining me and a huge thanks to
manscaped for uh sponsoring this video
but that is it for me today everybody i
will see you guys next time